yeah well I'm pretty shocking they
obviously have a plan to try and disrupt
people's day-to-day lives they try to
disrupt London Pride March uh last
weekend they try and block roads to stop
people getting to hospital appointments
and stop parents getting their children
to school this isn't legitimate protest
it's a deliberate attempt to disrupt the
day-to-day lives of other citizens uh
completely unacceptable I think the vast
majority of the public are appalled by
this tiny tiny very selfish minority so
we've changed the law recently um the
public order Act
2023 came into Force just a few weeks
ago gives the police much stronger
powers and thankfully when it comes to
roads you know we haven't seen those
enormous blockages on the M25 recently
on the Streets of London the protests
are now getting cleared within a matter
of a few minutes so a combination of
stronger laws and police action it's
really helping keep the Streets of
London clear when it comes to things
like sporting events and Wimbledon again
they're just disrupting the enjoyment of
of everyday
um citizens completely unacceptable now
the thankfully the interruption to
Wimbledon yesterday was was pretty brief
the people concerned have been arrested
and charged I think with aggravated
trespass we had a meeting the Home
Secretary and I met with sporting
organizations and the police yesterday
to encourage the organizers of sporting
events to increase their resources more
stewards more Marshals
um look at using searching on the way uh
in as far as they can and to consider
taking out injunctions which provides
more legal protection because if someone
breaches an injunction there's in a much
stronger criminal uh penalty so we did
at the Derby actually didn't they that's
right yeah exactly okay what about in
your previous job Chief secretary to the
treasury um I wonder if you could answer
this as with that hat that you used to
wear the FCA Financial conduct Authority
basically keeps an eye on the banks
calling them in today the big four to
say what are you doing about interest
rates when it comes to Savers well
that's a really good uh question
actually because we've seen mortgage
rates go up for people with mortgages as
the base rate has gone up the banking
and base rate's gone up but very often
some of the banks particularly actually
the the sort of traditional Banks
established Banks haven't increased the
rates they pay Savers commensurally some
of the smaller Challenger Banks actually
have but the some of the bigger
traditional Banks haven't and I think
that's that's wrong because it's um it's
not giving Savers
um the benefit of that rate so I think
the FCA are quite quite right to call
them in and and raise that forcefully
and should those interest rates mirror
what's happening as far as mortgage
rates are concerned you know increase at
the same
level well I mean traditionally that's
what you would expect because you know
Savers will get paid more for their
Savings mortgage holders end up paying
more on their mortgage you would expect
the two to go up together but that
hasn't happened in many cases what
Savers get has stayed quite low but the
mortgage rates have gone up so I think
the FCA are absolutely right to look at
that yeah I mean looking at this graphic
it's that's illustrating that that just
doesn't that just doesn't happen let's
see what happens as a result of that
meeting today although you've got to be
careful of regulatory overreach
apparently
yeah I mean clearly we don't want the
FCA intervening to like set the interest
rates the banks pay but equally we do
need Banks to behave in a way that's um
that's fair and reasonable and is
properly competitive as well talk to me
about what's going on with the House of
Commons and the House of Lords playing
ping pong with this um illegal
immigration Bill the bishop of Durham
um has said
um some youngsters could be wrongly
assessed with their age and as a result
deported and describe that as horrifying
and immoral
well I mean the legal immigration bill
um makes clear that if somebody would
suffer if serious and irreversible harm
then they won't get sent to Rwanda by
the way Rwanda is a country which the
unhcr itself uses um to send refugees to
so the unhcr thinks it's a safe country
um on the age Point
um I mean quite a few but maybe when I
was immigration Minister a couple of
years ago we found lots of people who
were in their early twenties uh would
pretend to be under 18 they'd say
they're 17 in order to get better
treatment under the system so one of the
things I think um the My the current
immigration minister is looking to do is
introduce uh more scientific age
assessment techniques so that might be
an X-Ray or that kind of thing uh we're
the only European country at the moment
actually not to use scientific age
assessment methods to determine if
somebody is under or over 18 so that
will really help but look the main point
about this is that crossing the English
Channel on a small boat is dangerous
it's illegal and it's unnecessary
because France is a safe country you
don't need to flee from France and you
know we do need to stop it the The
Crossings are down by 20 year on year
but the illegal immigration bill is the
highest sorry the last month was the
highest well so
um so this year as a whole so taking all
six months not just one month in
isolation but the the six months to the
end of June was down about 20 on last
year so some progress has been made we
need to do more and the illegal
immigration bill will help us do that
we've got to stop these boats completely
when will you see the first people going
to Rwanda because of course um the
courts have decided that it's illegal
again yeah well that depends um a little
bit on uh the Supreme Court so the
government lost in the court of appeal
although it was a split decision and the
law chief justice with the government
but we lost 2-1 that's right so we're
going to appeal uh to the Supreme Court
so we've got to wait and obviously have
that judgment
um the illegal immigration Bill
currently going through Parliament will
help we need to see you know exactly
what form that emerges from the
Parliamentary process in but the Prime
Minister has committed to stopping the
boats they're down 20 but a lot more to
do yeah but if the Supreme Court finds
against you as well it's all over isn't
it nobody going to London well I mean so
let's just wait and see what the
Judgment says and that's right isn't it
well I mean obviously the legal
immigration Bill itself changes the
changes statute changes the law so I
mean that obviously would be a provides
a an even stronger and different legal
basis to the one that exists today so
yes we're going through the Supreme
Court appeal route but we're also
introducing uh new law as well yeah in
the meantime talk to me about
um the next steps of the prime
minister's action plan anti-social
Behavior ah yes so we launched out a
couple months ago and it's being
implemented sort of starting this week
so one of the elements to that are
anti-social Behavior hotspot patrols uh
we're funding that a million pounds per
police force uh 10 pilot forces now
every single police force next April and
I was out and about in Lancashire and
surely this week they're launching their
ASB hotspot Patrols in Lancashire uh
this week across I think 14 towns in
Lancashire and it's getting officers to
intensively Patrol areas where there is
anti-social Behavior to make
interventions so to arrest people if
they're a committing ASB if they're
young people just divert them into more
constructive activities so surely for
example as a fantastic Youth Center
Activity Center called Inspire which
people can be diverted into clearly if
they're committing a criminal offense
then then prosecution can follow we're
also Banning nitrous oxide which is a
huge sort of scourge in many parts of
the country and we're also piloting in
10 police force areas and we're going to
roll it out across the country next year
instant Justice we're within 48 Hours
people have to clean up graffiti that
kind of thing to actually sort of make a
payback to the community if they are
committing antisocial Behavior I noticed
from your brief that you're also
responsible for um as well as crime and
policing fire as well
um quick thought about what happened in
Cambridge with the e-scooter that caught
on fire three people died and we've seen
also from in fact London Fire brigades
sat there and brought a video in about
e-scooters exploding yeah so I've
discussed this with Andy Rowe who's the
um the commissioner of the London fire
brigade and I think London had its first
e-scooter Vitality a few months ago so
this is a problem I think it's
particularly a problem where people have
sort of added their own battery pack to
a bike for example so we're very
concerned about this
um I know that the department for
business and trade are looking at the
regulations around battery safety and
we've got a cross-government group
working on this it is a concern a
growing concern and we need to make sure
these the batteries are inherently safe
themselves and we need to make sure
people are kind of storing them in the
right way but it is a it is a real
concern okay what are you going to do
about it well we're going to I think
we're looking at the um the fire there's
this product standards around these
batteries to make sure the batteries are
inherently
safe and they don't spontaneously catch
fire so we're reviewing the product
safety legislation okay do you think um
very briefly Before I Let You Go do you
think AI would be a good Minister for
crime
I don't know
I'd like to I'd like to think I would I
would do better than chat gbt but I mean
who who knows what's happening next next
time you want to ask some questions
instead of having me sit here and maybe
type it into chat GPT and see if it does
a better job do you think they'd answer
my questions
oh you did today actually it's about you
did it's always great to see you thanks
very much